I'm winning versus anybody I'll play
I'll really do I don't wanna play or you
know it's just this guy wanna beat you
know like I said before that still to go
I'm gonna change that I'm happy to
getting winning of course um especially
in the t-bag Stadium so it's pretty cool
too I don't really care because it's get
Tom Brady what's obvious when did you
see it game tonight oh he's always
chatty and personable and win or lose
that and something somebody said
yesterday hey Bill smile he is just Bill
Belichick in the Patriots and you know
what this is a good day for the National
Football League because look I
appreciate greatness yeah and I
recognize that the Patriots have
embarked and continued the best run that
the sport has ever seen but right it is
kind of nice when you feel like the
doors open for other teams sure because
it felt like it was gonna be Patriots
Plus whoever emerges from the scrum in
the NFC now maybe there's a scrum in the
AFC - yeah I mean you're right it brings
everything or at least brings the
Patriots back to reality I think that's
the big thing there and it's gonna give
teams a little more confidence who have
to face the Patriots here in the next
few weeks ago oh wait okay here's a
formula that won this game they're not
invincible I mean the Patriots do have
that type of aura I mean even last night
with a 17 nothing lead and Cyrus Jones
fumbling the ball we all go oh here we
go
come here it comes like they they had a
chance to kind of put the nail in the
coffin and then it's oh my gosh it's
1710 and here we go again
so megive teams in the NFL confidence
who faced them and you're right it's
just gonna make the AFC a little bit
more closer a little bit more of a fight
and the put away came when the Ravens
were up 20 for 20 they got the ball with
757 left in the third quarter they went
on a 14 play I mean yard drive it will
shoot up more than eight minutes a clock
and that was the moment where okay
that's it they've just overpowered the
Patriots you don't see that very often I
mean you don't see anything that
happened last night to the Patriots very
often the way the game started just
being really overwhelmed on both sides
of the football
getting in no rhythm and then you know
of course to turnover and then the hurry
up offense kind of
got the the momentum back on their side
to a degree but you know you thought oh
okay the Patriots getting the ball in
the second half and here they were
they're driving down the big fumble
return Marlin Humphrey picks that up
runs for a touchdown you all okay so
breathing room for the Baltimore Ravens
I mean this was a huge moment you know
Julian Edelman he doesn't make mistakes
like this ever really so that's really
rare and then yes you're right to add to
that a drive where you go man they need
a drive to help their defense out to win
this game and they just just were a
physical machine just kind of pounding
it down the throat of the New England
Patriots
the Patriots 37 points allowed last
night to the Ravens Chris were the most
allowed by the Patriots in a road game
since September 2014 41 to 14 Wow the
onda Cincinnati game after losing to the
Chiefs and you know in a weird sort of
way
it's kind of good for the rest of us
that the Patriots don't play this
weekend because we've got time before we
hop on the whole Patriots are done
narrative and if they were playing a
tough game this week and if they had to
go to Philadelphia this weekend maybe
that would be a focal point but you know
I cuz you know what happens it's it's
once a year this idea catches fire that
the Patriots are done right and they
thrive on that right and I think it
actually hurts the Patriots that they
don't get a chance to truly thrive on
all of the things that we're gonna be
saying today about how it went poorly
for the Patriots take it away 13 days
until they play yeah that's that's never
good and then you know is sometimes with
by weeks too you know you know I'm not
always in favor of them because guys can
get out of the routine a little bit you
just kind of get out of full-fledged
battle mode and you take a vacation or
another vacation but you just get off
some of your details go ahead but this
helps this I think this gives Bill
Belichick the ammunition to keep his
guys focused because they got a horrible
taste in their mouths as they start
their box I I agree with that and I
think this is the other thing too
they're just a little different about
the Patriots teams maybe than we've seen
in years before and you know hey we
needed to see a team beat them before we
really could say oh this is an issue
with the team we knew the old line had
some issues right well you know we saw
the Baltimore defense really overwhelm
them especially the start of the game
until the hurry-up offense started they
were they
our truly dominating well you got two
defenses after the bye and the Eagles
and the Cowboys who can kind of do
similar things really I would say have
more athletic defensive lines other
thing is the other side of the ball Mike
I just find this interesting
the Patriots you know last night was the
first night they were forced to be big
right forced to be like oh wow it's
three tight ends or oh it's two tight
ends and I'm running back and a fullback
like they want to have their DBS on the
field they want to move people around
linebackers we're confusing you and they
lost that advantage and they're a team
that is usually built on size but
defense this year they have a little bit
of a lack of real big people like that
and again the Eagles and Cowboys are big
on the offensive line so this is just a
little bit of a you know again a little
crack in the armor or whatever it may be
but it's gonna give teams that play them
a little bit of a hey they're the
Patriots and they're good but if we take
the fight to them especially up front
you know we should win that we are the
more talented team at least these upper
echelon teams there and then just be
interesting to see as we go forward
after the game defensive back Devin
McCourty the Patriots explained that the
Baltimore Ravens controlled everything
on the night here's McCourty because we
struggle stopping the run it pretty much
gave him control of the game you know
possession down the distance I think
they got to be comfortable all game we
got him a couple third and long as we
were able to get off the field before
the majority of the game I think they
were able to play it on their terms and
you know I think that's what probably
hurt us the most 37 minutes time of
possession for the Ravens 210 rushing
yards on 41 attempts when you look at
Lamar Jackson stat line it does not
scream out MVP right 17 220 363 yards a
touchdown pass 16 rushing attempts for
61 yards and two touchdowns but to do it
against the Patriots the team that has
mastered the first and second-year
quarterback yeah the team that always
bedevils anyone and everyone that they
face to have Lamar Jackson and that
Ravens offense do what they did
the Patriots defense in a year when we
were saying oh this Patriots defensive
like the 85 Bears better than the 85
Bears not last night and it really does
give the NFL a different vibe heading in
to the month of November no it does I
mean well we know now that you know hey
Baltimore's for real I mean that's the
first thing we can say you know whether
they lose another game mean of course
they probably will it doesn't really
matter but it's shown that you know they
they can beat anybody on a given day and
then it does show that the Patriots are
beatable and to your point with Lamar
Jackson and you know III think you're
you know you're spot-on like the stats
aren't gonna scream like oh wow sexy MVP
it was the timing of some of the plays
he made through the game whether it was
the first third down of the game he's
about to get sacked and he throws a ball
to him Marquis Hollywood Brown as he's
falling down and Hollywood Brown dives
and makes the play it's other plays
where you go oh the Patriots got him
right and then he runs to the left and
just darts through a hole and Kyle van
Noy
like breaks his ankles where you don't
see that happen very often he gets down
to the one-yard line or you know it's
just a number or the other play that got
him down to the one-yard line he has the
cutback it was just the magnitude of the
plays where drives usually stall out
when you play the Patriots but yet he
was physically a gifted enough at times
to overcome their scheme you know it's
like we talked about with really good
players and you know I witnessed this a
little bit like Michael Vick like you
know the Bucks you you could talk about
preparing for Michael Vick all you want
until you got in the field and saw him
like whoa this guy's faster than the guy
we had in scout team all week you know
it can it can change your approach and
of course it's a game changer in general
yeah and Jackson also this comes from
NFL research first player with a passing
touchdown and multiple rushing
touchdowns against the Patriots since
Ronnie Brown in the Wildcat game of 2008
and you know we've seen this time and
again how mobile quarterbacks the devil
the Patriots and no matter what Bill
Belichick does to prepare his team and I
don't know why this happens why do you
think it happens the mobile quarterbacks
have that kind of success against
Belichick defense well I think the may
be the number one thing I would say more
than anything is you know bill bill
tries to you know stop everything stop
your bread and butter but I would more
than anything just look at their edge
guys historically have not been like
the most athletic game-changing type
guys you know they've never had those
those edge pass rushers where we just go
oh man
if you don't block that guy or
double-team them you know you're screwed
is an offense so they don't necessarily
always have those athletes to corral
those type of guys they do it more with
oh we're gonna confuse them you know
with with our coverage in the backend
and try to you know keep them in the
pocket and all those things and that's
it that's great but like we said it's
just a little harder said than done or
you know done than said I should say
when it comes to guys like Lamar Jackson
and the Patriots schedule was a lot
easier than hard early in the year we
saw them run roughshod yeah shot shot
roughshod over the competition through
the first eight weeks now after the bye
Chris it's at Philadelphia then the home
game against the Cowboys then a trip to
Houston to take on deshaun Watson and
the Texans then a visit from the Chiefs
week 14 we will learn a lot about the
Patriots in the next four games we will
I mean it's definitely a step up in
competition you know and the other thing
too just wanted the the scrambling
quarterback thing this kind of came to
my mind I should have clarified this
even a little more the that's the great
advantage the scrambling quarterbacks
have on New England is this it takes
away one of New England's greatest
advantages which is their schematically
creativity in it because when you
creativity on a week to week basis when
you play guys like Lamar Jackson and Cam
Newton you have to worry about all the
different runs and different things
so therefore bill might not be able to
be as creative with blitzes or stunts
upfront or doubling some guy and doing
some crazy zone over here to stop a
passing game he's got to worry about
okay yeah that's great I'd like to stop
that in the passing game but then I'm a
gap short maybe in the run game of this
so then oh there goes that creative
coverage you see behind it and those are
the little things that there's the
scrambling quarterbacks do to them if I
understand what you're saying you can't
plan for every contingency with a guy
who thrives on kale
no doubt right now when it becomes
backyard football it's just a my faster
than then a my faster than anyone you
can chase me with exactly that to the
good and also to the degree of like oh
he wants to take away
Hollywood Brown on a third and seven
okay great but now
that's one less set of eyes on you know
Lamar Jackson is he's scrambling on
third and six or seven you know it's
just those little issues where hey the
Patriots we know they got some good
players and Brady is the legend and all
those things whatever but the greatness
of the Patriots usually is their
schematically can throw a team on a
weekly basis and with these type of
quarterbacks it almost simplifies them
for lack of a better phrase
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports